i want to welcome you all to  the 2021 film independent directors  close-up panelists what an inadequate  term for the five filmmakers we have  here today  chloe zhao kelly reichert lee isaac  chung emerald fennell  eliza hitman the thing with luck is  actually the hard work of a lot of  people on your team  for me really it was just about making  it fun and playful  and seem like we had all the time in the  world  you know there's no place that's really  safe except when they are in this clinic  it was a logistical nightmare i could  only shoot there between  12am and 4am originally  i could just never afford an editor but  now i just really like editing  i started off just writing a lot of  memories down i saw  a narrative arc and i started to shape  all of that  stay healthy and stay well everybody  but i don't know it's the answer really